depuis l'obtention de son diplôme il ya
un an christelle baudet partage son
temps entre tours et angers dans le loir
et cher où elle a son petit atelier dans
l'ancienne mairie dans ses 30 mètres
carrés elle crée ses collections et
confectionne des vêtements sur mesure
pour femmes et enfin le sur-mesure ça me
plaît c'est pas forcément ma tasse de
thé mais je trouve que quand on est dans
la création il faut que le vêtement que
la personne a choisi il faut qu'ils
veuillent parfaitement c'est le plus je
dirais de ce qu'on trouve dans le
commerce
alors c'est un tissu très particulier
moi c'est la première fois que je
travaillais pas dessus comme fort donc
pour moi ça c'est une grande première
mais c'est ça que j'adore en fait
jusqu'en 2016 cette jeune femme
dynamique mère de quatre enfants était
clerc de notaire
passionné par le droit elle a toujours
gardé dans un coin de sa tête sa passion
pour la mode ou 15 ans d'ancienneté dans
le notariat
je n'ai envie de tourner la page et puis
en fait m'adonner à ma passion
j'avais pas mal d'économies de côté qui
m'ont permis de d'opter pour ce choix-là
de reconversion en disant voilà tu tu
vas essayer d'exercer sa passion essayé
d'approfondir d'approfondir plein de
petites choses qui sont techniques si
voilà tu veux donner après le meilleur
de toi même c'est le début de l'aventuré
elle suit deux ans de formation au cfa m
de saint cyr sur loire et obtient deux
prix un régional et un national pour ses
créations en 2018
sa force l'originalité de ses vêtements
opéré ajoute des accessoires son petit
plaisir c'est avec les vêtements pour
enfants que christelle a commencé là
elle et c'est un nouveau tissu pour une
manche de manteaux pour petites filles
ça c'est pour ma fille pour ma vie mais
qui fait partie de mes petits mannequins
en fait sur les défilés
donc ça sera sûrement une pièce de
collection pour se faire connaître
christelle mise sur les défilés dans la
région son prochain grand rendez vous
avec le public est en février 2020 à
tour
[Musique]